- [Dave] Is this the place?
- Yeah.
- What's it say on
your map, dirty alley?
- Yeah.
- Where is this guy?
- You have the goods?
- Oh, yeah.
You got the money?
- Is a check okay?
- Oh, definitely.
- Certainly.
- Give.
Mm, my little kinder.
You are Heino's future.
- [Dave] Oh, is it all there?
- Yeah, $57.
- Let's go, let's go cash it.
- Not tonight.
It's not open tonight.
- Tomorrow?
- Bright and early.
- (Singing) Chicky,
chicky, chicky
bump, bump, bump, bump.
- (upbeat music)
- They don't cash German checks,
they don't fit into the slot.
- Heino!
- [Chris] This check
is worthless, now.
- We've gotta find
that crazy German
and get our baby back.
- I know where his mother lives.
- Old lady Heino?
Where?
- (Upbeat music)
- What are you doing?
- There's no one here.
- (Laughter)
- Did she see me?
Did she see me?
- I don't even
know who that was.
That was someone else's mother.
Where's Heino?
- (German music)
- C'mon, c'mon
Kinder. All aboard.
Das train.
Hoo, hoo.
Choo, choo!
- You know, he's probably
grinding that baby
up into schnitzel, right now,
and feeding it to Dirk
Nowitzki, for all we know.
- Dave.
- What?
- It's the semifinals.
- Oh no, we gotta
go get this guy.
- This is a nine star show!
- What are we doing out here?
Let's go!
- [Host] Okay, let's introduce
our first contestant.
- It's a pleasure to be here.
- I feel like a lion.
A lion in the jungle.
About to pounce!
- These guys are great.
- You're looking
at me all wrong.
Do it again and I'll
stab you in the face
with a soldering iron.
- Whoever wins is gonna go
on to the finals. (laughs)
Wait til I introduce you,
wait til I introduce you.
Ladies and gentlemen, Roy!
Hi, I'm not gay.
I'm an alligator.
- You sure this
isn't the finals?
- I've been looking for...
The bastards who brought
me to this party.
- Earlier this morning,
I was just taking a leak,
holding my winky.
Thank you.
- Hang Gangbang Wang, everybody.
Boy, he gave us something
to think about, right?
I don't know how, how we're
gonna make any kind of decision.
Luckily, I don't have
to do that. (laughs)
I can't believe this is
the semifinals. I mean...
- Heino!
- [Heino] Pour the beer.
We are all good kinder.
Drink your beer.
Prost.
(burps)
Sausage?
- Are you sure this
is the way to Germany?
- Yeah, we gotta go
through Poland, first;
but this is the way.
- I've never thought
it'd look like this.
- It looks a lot like
the American west.
- Oh, right.
- Heino!
- Get in.
- Baby!
- [Dave] I thought
you'd be dead.
- [Chris] Yeah, me too.
Thanks for watching the episode.
We've hidden a secret button,
it's on our favorite
weirdo walking moment.
- Hi
- That's the moment. Bye